good afternoon and welcome to the live
stream here at the Chess Club on Perry
Coulson I'm gonna take on all
challengers with my partner Jonathan
Franz MA and yeah I'm here holding it
down in the chat it's good to see some
of you guys you guys are always already
asking the big questions like what's
Perry's writing oh well Luke hazard good
to see you again sit up look all right
we'll reveal that in just a minute what
kind of controls we looking forward
today we're looking for mostly that four
minutes five minutes occasionally we'll
throw in a three minute but we're
looking for five minute time control
today okay all right so we have a four
minute challenge in here Rosie mint
let's do it all right Rosie mint yes
okay Rosie mint what's he gonna play
always in 1870 question mark oh my
goodness you don't really know thank you
no we don't much more much less here we
go right but I know how berry plays yes
you do this supposed to be expected good
to see it John Kerr disco who's freezing
up in New York yeah Big Chill here it
was like negative five when I woke up
this morning it's Fahrenheit so okay
what's your play involved here it's Mike
playing on Friday sure is
let's do it I like the most
thanks Humberto I'll go back here these
general plans are either to march on the
queenside or play in the middle class
okay this has got me concerned here
these first time good to see a Ruben
Garcia all right it's good to have new
people and yeah so there's a link in the
chat if you guys do want to challenge
this st. Louis Chess Club Challenge us
on Lee chess he's gonna do some stuff
over here though he's got all these
pawns working for earlier I beat Viktor
Tim apparently yesterday so he wants
revenge only watch my man you play so
play think we should take here on it
only a fight on the F is half in the
control room what's going on in there
well in house fighting going on your
stuff see what happens he's gonna come
down here he's gonna play a g5 sorry
John yeah we're trying to have he's
gonna play at different times of the day
so that everybody can play cuz I know
it's most of our things at least for the
moment I guess what do you guys is this
what they see on the screen or am I
looking at something else what do they
see on the screen what do you guys see
no so I can't even see us so I stopped
smiling right don't smile quit smiling
that's good because I hate smiling right
so we're gonna get in there and give
Rose right in a few seconds here
and then he's attacking my kingside like
they always do when I played the
Sicilian every time every time they just
do this all the time
oh my goodness checkmate yes that mr.
Johnson is you can't see me yet I'm sure
you will at some point we got our best
people running around like crazy he's
breaking my house I know they had to do
it every time Jenna right now we're here
right children rights I'm not sure all
right
he's gonna check me then good to see you
guys I was going out there you can see
if we can survive this crazy pawn march
here I guess that's the risk you take
when you play this too silly you know
isn't it yeah no no I have survived this
before little big yellow is she okay so
it's me is that does anyone else see any
yellow screen screen looks yellowish
playing brilliant move brilliant
brilliant move here yeah take that I
don't know if that's brilliant button
trade on g2 yeah I did didn't I nothing
you get some screen time dance the roof
we have a lot of people in the shadows
around here this is the hosta date video
even Luke hazard seeing the yellow
you bishop trumped my bishop yep I did
didn't I well you sacrificed a sacrifice
yes that's what I did no there's no
pawns and father was sacrificed it's
genius that I sacrificed my issue good
so we survive we survive survive losing
one point will everywhere I see but
someone check me try to put everything
like a minute I think the theme maybe
it's more yellow but the video is fine
ok we don't do that that wouldn't let's
just get safe we'll just put that right
there
I don't know I figured something out
well he's up a piece so yeah I gave up
tonight oh my goodness we are down in
time we are not doing well Oh Ice King
I'm trying I am trying I'm trying my
best so you got a plate today I do play
game in the ninth I am I'm gonna go from
playing for second place prize money
actually to be honest with you it's a
real big deal it is a big deal I guess
you're gonna pick up the pace here okay
full concentration whoa all right full
concentrations oh I don't know I think
we're in trouble I'll just talk to
people okay you talk to people are dead
what's going on see you and me what's
going on can we play a 10-minute game or
five to chill just well let you all see
we just probably need to play games that
have a little bit more time yeah we are
practicing we're getting parry warmed up
here we are along classical games
playing a classical pace when we're
ratings be revealed so you can see the
ratings there on the screen that's our
club count rating Perry is about a
thousand rated or so he is about a
thousand engine shows white is much
better and you actually actually see
that unless
I assume you might be trolling us but is
that is that a real thing feline
can you actually do that only chess oh I
blew it I shoulda played see the
evaluation also once you come here if
you want to talk to me good game thanks
for the game can they actually see the
evaluation really
or is he just I think was crazy crazy
all right Victor I'm gonna help me out
here Victor I'm going to couch it fast
this is a three minute game all right
Victor Gaucho also our rating was like
twenty thirty or something so you got to
make it go over
well I'm trying I'm trying oh that's
only do the best much better with an
extra person hovering over well that's
gonna be much better yes shouting yeah
okay Victor chair move I also love how
Denison drew is just obscured well okay
you can see my I don't know if you want
it that way okay here we go let's go
let's see how I think I always end in
here you there's a lot of good ways to
play against the Kings Indian or servers
but Perry you didn't build the triangle
no I didn't build the trying you have to
build try what happens going on here
stamping alright I don't know Fred
define physical so far so good so far so
good
let's do Volta fish appear titanium
friends says Jesus yeah okay weird this
guy right here the right side of this
between c2 I love my partners here I
love my partners here so just like push
this guy all the way up no nope yeah you
wanna play on the queenside bit like
eventually if you must place them don't
don't play nice okay you want to play
before so you can prepare for before
with Adrian do this okay all right
guess you your worry is so what does my
worry I have lots of worries words when
you play a three that they can play a
[ __ ] and lucky no if I develop this
guy right here Jenna right right here
all right
i Danny
have you played Luke Luke saying hi
Danny Goodwin forced me last time come
bleep lady for now you play Luke they're
probably calls Danny ever yeah I was
this didn't even though this is d for
now yeah before before yes yes yes I
thought so yes before now yes that was
my move what time control do you prefer
half-hour
sour would you play like one game this
right here we got to keep it going so a
lot of people come yes yes three or four
or five minutes that seems to be a good
good range I also kind of depends on
your rating a little bit and probably a
little bit one of them were time if
you're pretty decent far okay you played
before cuz you want to play c5 to c5
work here he's doing it I'm doing it I'm
doing it I hope it works
yeah oh I like it I like it well you
stopped Anderson it's got your back with
Barry Coulson has a very deep positional
understanding yeah from time to time I
can understand things but I just try to
play the best move it doesn't always
work out that way but I do the best I
can all right where we at here we're
okay in time what is you gonna do take
back right here looks okay the defendant
is not too okay Lisa it's not defended
Yassir will be here in town very soon
very soon for the Karin's couple I told
you it wasn't defended now we're down a
few doesn't do anything I'm not playing
the people and every five blundering
movies no take something there I think
something all right
there do something good job now I can
play night 9 play Knight d5 maybe
probably put your rooks wherever your
rooks go first ok I trust your judgment
you'll put them in their spots ok no
right mister 1743 day and wardo is
challenging us ouch Oh
take our wire right here also I suppose
you had Bishop to b5 there which would
skew earth Queen double yes that wasn't
would've been a great move right now
that I looked up to see the board it's
too late now
yeah alright this is fine
good game so far but Victor there's been
a game
we can still play that
that defended gee it's okay be careful
about Bishop f5 coming what are you
doing I wonder if there's a button we
got this new Mouse in something's gone
wrong with it yes mess it up immediately
fast we need to play fast isn't need to
play fast all right you might be four
here which attacks the night Anna Bishop
all right went on time that's your best
bet
Knight blocks Knight blocks night blocks
D for D for just prints go fast your
queen oh no go fast fast fast fast fast
oh now just some pre move remove
something something or whatever whatever
how this was like an Inca meter is there
some delay it looks like he gained
seconds but take it take it's too late
all right we need to win its we need to
win one here yeah okay
Oh Chester Oh miss is risk oh sorry
let's go all right let's go all right
wait let's go is weak you've fallen
under mm this is very upsetting I'm
sorry we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna win at this time we're gonna get
it back I promise we're gonna get it
back I promise
we've sent the 1,000 read a guy in here
to maintain our 2,000 readings so we
expect a lot you know with my
expectations
yeah very solid even risco probably felt
played like a million games he played a
few so if you had this position before I
don't know there's something
despereaux's taught me this isn't your
deepest GoPro tennis ball has taught me
this okay that's good
oh she's probably using an engine though
so what engine risk oh good so the guy
remembers three two there's a problem
with changing time controls two is you
got to constantly adjust a new new
control you got to play five minutes
that would be my advice but you know are
you gonna take ping buns are they
stronger are they weak well what are the
deep positional future Dennis say that
these two pawns right here is okay
Dennis Boros Dennis Poros what's Dennis
Larousse take all right I'm just joking
makes a great guy
they were playing D for fast question
fast answer tea coffee it's not my turn
so loud today who can hear your hands on
your hips yeah Oh a good easy win we
want to play you will long well we were
just talking about this - fair-weather
says which is more valuable - bishop or
the night you know my partner Jonathan
trots definitely thinks bishops are more
more valuable and all the time the night
does hop over you you will get your hops
over bishops better but in real life the
night Forks you so it's a it's a really
tough call there
yeah that's game I played a night fork
to me so I don't know what was that Mike
now but yeah just sound like my comment
I'm taking it I'm just gonna take it
Mike Gummer I'm taking it's funny that
they say that about you because City ace
you're doing beginner breakdown now yeah
that was my conversation right and I'm
are you ready to reveal your your
special that's coming up soon or we're
just gonna leave it at mystery I there
may blitz bouncy may be making a return
that is exciting news blitz bounty yeah
so if you guys haven't seen obviously
you have to get on YouTube right now and
you just took a piece let's go don't
know watch this all right one splits
Bonnie wait till the took a pond
alright alright alright
play something
like Queen afore put your queen by its
gang you know yeah something something
sometimes they get checkmated sometimes
it's maca risk oh I'm gonna do it oh you
pieces by ski all right it is good yeah
Bishop's dominating the air game pawns
are better because they can Queen think
machine analysis found bishops are worth
three point one five and material Mike
was great at beginner breakdown no
because it's all Dennis's fault you can
see more of that on beginner break
through all Dennis's fault every Monday
at like 7:30 or something sometime all
Dennis's fault that's okay that's okay
that's alright with an increment it's
gonna be a difficult flanking operation
here
yes it is just blame Dennis it's okay
this is ridiculous though losing against
yes is really bad it's really bad really
really bad
oh he saves us gloating he's so happy
he's so happy
is he coming in tonight right now just
to jump in the stream and be like ooh a
flight tomorrow at 1:00 a.m. I'll be at
your club prepare yourself we'll see you
Alberto's I'm Dennis Lu on the night
shift holding the club open for you yes
Jeff's work becomes an f4 look at his
game challenge chat with us because this
game is over he has plenty of time to
come we'll see you at 4 come join the
stream tell us how you felt about this
game the Queen sacrifice line sacrifice
Nick good move
alright you got lucky I'm never
listening to anybody again he's getting
terrible yeah it was a tough show we
climbed up over the 2000 all right
Turkish Johnny Turkish Johnny says like
9 9 9 rated that's perfect for us well
let's get a win it's gonna win alright
sack equals very dubious but playable
okay I'll be kicked out if I lose this
game yeah that's probably a good policy
Oh
r.i.p Perry ninety nine something - 2019
alright here we go this is our opening
right here this is it there's one
opening Perry Coulson knows that's right
this is it we're gonna crush I'm gonna
crush this cuz I'm out we maxed out at
nine nine nine rated hopefully there's
no more room for a potential and maxing
out who desperately wants to be over a
thousand rated I guess she does just as
badly as we need to get the 2000 hey
guys please keep playing people from the
top I've been waiting for a while now
okay but we just you know we got to get
a win and it'll you see a nine nine nine
yeah we got to get a win and no
disrespect to maxing out so far playing
a fantastic game he is well above rating
we just got a gift very chance here yes
horrible last week was much better but
we're gonna get in the swing of things
here windmill of doom is an easy wind
allegedly doing huh sometimes I say that
and then they're like 2500 ray themself
yeah
King chaser it's not about it's not all
about getting to 2,000 right now it's
about you know stopping the momentum
that's going in the wrong direction we
gotta get some wins and then you know it
all start flowing it'll come together a
place some of the higher rated plants
right we'll take we'll take it back
we'll get it back we'll get it back get
it back
ya know but so far fantastic game here
it is Mexico this is obviously playing
that was protected in my friend
we took it that's up I feel like up to
that point it was a fantastic game now
it's nice to go yes I probably would've
taken by a night efficient you got to
get yeah but I would have probably have
taken on e5 with my knight if I were you
whatever yeah so they did this line he
doesn't regain the palm and ruined your
structure so I felt like that was maybe
our opportunity to really strike but I
should probably take it one time I
shouldn't give up the file probably just
connect your hooks so that we don't lose
the file Bishop what b7 should be so
much cheer okay do your thing out well
sure let's see if I've got some moment
just gonna get stuff out yeah you might
get the pawn back and whatever
we'll keep we just need to win we just
we just need to win what are they saying
how bad I am no no all good things all
good things sure sure sure sure all good
I miss been fine gold yeah of course
[Music]
rooty for rook d4 or d4 get all our
stuff in alright that's pretty much 2000
level on this side bring your stuff out
it's all year 2000 on the Internet
develop your stuff look at that rook in
the corner what's it doing how about
right here great moves
alright fantastic okay yeah do you feel
like waiting at some point probably
should have taken the pawn back I'm
gonna play e5 immediately you're gonna
take his rook we're so excited
hopefully maxing out doesn't see it
we'll just grab that rule we shouldn't
say
they can hear us they can't hear us well
we can't because you know Dennis isn't
there neither like muted our mics we
didn't know gang we've said like this
whole time basically oh he did let me
out there just turn on pair he is the
best who's cheering me on
yeah Bertos oh just do it tell bare toes
maybe we can win this game this is a
promising promising game maybe we can
win this one all right Robert Lamm asks
what my rating is by the way loves my
streams yeah it's a it's no longer 1900
I believe I've fallen so low as like
1875 after the staff tournament I have
worked away I might I dropped a log
that's all right even Jonathan Schwartz
loses a game from time to time yeah
lately it's just always I know I'm fired
now that's Barry's fired what oh yes he
is my boss so if it wasn't so true but
one for the fact that I lose every game
you really want to play me now everyone
should play me now washed up a class
player thanks fine just take the pawn
sure do I accept Facebook requests I
don't have a Facebook
yeah I don't really have any form of
social media those an accident oh there
was an accident thousand I was a mouse
slip that was a mouse slip
I was a total mouse slip it's all right
we got it was a mouse to be a battle now
there's a mouse slip this I was already
kind of writing this up as an easy win
there's a mouse slip
take your time maxing out think about it
thank God
good game good game yeah he sped it up
right there that's all right we won all
right quietly concentrate do I ever play
the Evans gambit no I don't really play
any game it's yeah terrible chest can be
excellent TV you don't play any gambits
ever no there's only one gambit that's
okay Queen seven you played the only
okay one the Halloween gambit yeah I
mean it's bad objectively but you know
you can play it on the stream
probably d3 is the square bishop well he
come down here I have to move it again
no you play Bishop a5 though in that
situation and then all this Knights get
pinned and then good stuff happens
walking dude good glad you didn't walk
behind the camera she said I might like
knock it over are you out here okay yeah
it comes like a night let's get one last
look at Denis Lill before he gets this
haircut so people will see him next time
and say hey nice haircut
yeah well bad haircut yeah okay alright
good bye alright see this what this this
comment was held for profanity
it said are you Sarge n am Maurice doing
Karen's cup commentary will allow this
and answer the question yep they will
all be here so in addition we'll have
you know commentary it'll be just like
the sink filled cup so we have Jane yes
sir and Maurice will have additional
commentary in another language will have
the commentary over at the kingside
diner for those that are here live in
attendance so yeah it's actually going
to be it's gonna be huge
I do something though how to do
something for Anthem sakes let's play
[Music]
Bishop saying this Bishop right here
yeah oh thank you thank you thank you
spare me that tonight just like this my
pieces hanging and then that's a part of
it too it's developing your stuff and
changing anything you also got to take
theirs when they hang on and that's it
that's right against 2000
I play this no everyone do that yeah and
it's sort of a part of it you guys know
if you guys are playing us that there's
two people here giving move right stuff
it's like if you're playing your chest
bras or some other team where it's like
multiple people sort of well advertise
that this is a communal account so
occasionally you're playing more than
one person at a time so beware we're not
hiding the effect we're not I've watched
every trance opening video multiple
times every strap you yeah W Bennett
he's super active I think that actually
I believe him because he's in every
every comment saying real nice today w
Bennett tell me about it
so yeah he's really active on our
YouTube channel which is is great to
have you here take this guy
jana and Alexandra do hand and brain all
the time against viewers mister yeah
there's a lot of accounts out there and
you usually know you playing multiple
people it is a bit shady or if you're
not unlike some account that's obviously
mm-hmm you know multiple people but this
one obviously is he's up in my space
he's got a lot of space yeah you know
he's got a lot of space thank you for
the kind words mister Cyprien
alright see you guys about it new hazard
it's a tough one
it feels a lot quieter without Dennis
LaRue here I know I know I see I see I
see
so to something like F for work because
that attacks the Queen your Queen
protects the G to pawn and your threaten
is the night yeah with a huge wad
pissant candy yeah so I'm trying to
calculate if he does I'm Poisson when we
take his Knight does he have like a
checkmate I don't know so if he takes
off the Sun it takes all right rook so
at minimum right we could take back but
we should calculate if we take his
Knight
so if you take something we take his
Knight we win a piece that's true then
he's done bad stuff on g2 so that's the
part we got to calculate yeah what's
wrong we took your piece Luke give it to
us and I trust in Perry's calculation
abilities oh you're so general intuition
you're so kind
you got to be positive because we need
we're gonna win this this is gonna
propel us back battle this is this is it
let's get these points back Jonathan
Sean's helped me out a lot but I had
made played some okay moves I think my
bishop move was all right the Bishop g4
it was pretty good move then to be
honest just to you know talk about Perry
Coulson as a person I do feel like it's
with you it's it's streaky like you're
you can play like the best and then you
that's what insistency is yeah it's
about being consistent can I take this
gun back I thought if he was gonna do
something silly okay that would be Queen
III right away because it takes a final
check okay okay
all right they're just something they'll
few bishops ticked this guy's attacked
right here yes how we just play back
here again
you took this piece we're getting away
with it maybe
trickier but I'll sit but mine is this
leech s yes it is you can go on and
challenge st. Louis chess club to a game
if you're looking to play Perry
Coulson's yes that's right we need to
move our queen because you see four or
five pairs Paulson is rated about 1000
check right here looks like if you
didn't know that's a USCF does st. Louis
Chess Club love Lee chess better than
chess calm no they just came to us first
so weird we're doing it on this side
they've helped us out a lot too with
trade some stuff cuz he's gonna be
taking your each bond see how he's gonna
play Bishop takes h3 and then oh right
here didn't trick me
you don't want that yeah I mean it's
probably not checkmate but you're making
it a little scary well so if you can
take it and play Queen age to play Queen
age to finish - yep hopefully we can do
it but I feel like those ways they're
probably we coulda made it not as Gary
first when we first started this - I
guess we just just called us like we had
a question about how to stream and they
just called us and said do this and
we're like okay well do they've been
really good to us don't play Queen age -
yeah when I was probably depend upon
with the bishop is what I'm thinking
yeah anything looks alright bit tenuous
but we're hanging in there yeah you
should be able to catch this later on
YouTube so big shout out to those
watching us not live really called you
yeah I mean they were probably listening
to us stream on Twitch or something and
they call this good
this guy into action missed meet what we
must meet who missed me
no one ever would miss around that all
right so you guys pick it up that's
right no no I mean we're doing fine
we're up one time take it and then take
it to give me a check his group singing
so he's got a trade take this take the
Queen look at that Oh God
good game Luke hazard very good game
that was a tough fight it was a tough
fight copán and he's first up racing top
köppen and I think open and many times
he was first up so you know hoping
hoping rex would play in our last staff
tournament he's played in staff
tournaments before so what's up copening
nice to play you again we had a good
match last time let's make this one an
easy match let's go oh he's playing the
London system system alright thanks Luke
that's a good game but I got I got some
new moves for this London system we're
gonna play that move right there yeah
takes three six was simply winning the
rook on the last game yeah
yes he was a good unusual that is a
London but they broke their triangle
so I don't really think black has any
promise here so
I think we're doing all right
yeah let's go yeah today is Brian
Chester's day but he's been for some
reason celebrating celebrating his
birthday party for his own birthday
really weird we are like it started it
started off bad but we're coming back
you know we were over 2,000 camembert
did we felt like 1970 or something we
had some big wins we're coming back we
are we're coming back Perry is a Raging
Bull osius right now get in the shot so
people can see you
Ryan Chester manager is in the house do
you actually want to get in it but don't
play did you want to just finish this
guy off yeah
like quickly there's easily all right
come in here start him suggesting moves
planning general rules said not to just
whatever he's doing just say no not that
way without offering anything that's
generally a good of us Ryan you're still
undefeated on this he's not under the
sprint is he yeah so yeah yeah bringing
up as a Gary Coulson plays the people
not Ryan Chester plays the P move raise
your hand if you were in here raise your
hand if you work here see now that a
nights powerhouse it's a monster he's
not gonna kick it away how do you send
it challenge and Danny can you spam the
link again because we got you can go to
leech s calm right we were so Ryan what
time control are you gonna be fine ten
are you taking over thing are you gonna
be just playing a few games you want me
to leave after I finding in on a winning
streak he's gonna kick me out your
rating is still a little bit down on the
base a little bit yeah my gosh you guys
are mean there's no love and chest no
there's no love in chess
come sound already now we think about
that night Ryan Chester now anything
about that night it's good night that's
a really good night brutal you see any
big Forks coming yeah I'm not gonna get
forked I already I already played that
game all right
I already played that game now what
that's not right here ratings no there's
a bishop there okay that's our senior
night no I'm so strong about that
LightSquared bishop on the board this
guy is hanging right here
so let's protect it somehow how about
checking them
take that take that part or not
in this guy's hanging
now if he takes on a six with a queen do
not take his bishop no no no just think
because I see that just saying I'm not
even that bad if he takes on a six of
them then I'm gonna play my room who is
the scrub talking all big off-screen Oh
whoop so this is one here it's windmill
of doom Harry should plan because he
means I'm so weak Barry should play me
he's the only one I can beat so maybe
that's true maybe it's a troll but will
long bring in the heat today and then if
we win this game we're gonna be three
and three what's up Caleb demo in the
house
Caleb Denby will be three and three who
wins this game our average rating in
this room went up tremendously yes it
did what's happening here copening is
considering he's calculating
how badly are we crushing this guy
copening is ocularly see the meat yet
thousands of what see the mate see the
mate
the only Caleb Ben be strong enough to
see made here you just worry about
taking all those pieces and stuff what
are you still well I suppose I could
take birth right here as Detective just
for the records I would be attacking his
Queens it's true but I'm just letting
you know all right let's play here then
he brain good to see you uh Qataris good
to see you you pinned him I did got a
pin it to win it I did pin them but how
could I complete the pin oh I got it I
got it
do we went on time yet no dang it we do
not went on time yet I only do like
three minutes five minutes yeah it's at
the point where like my epon is right
here yeah well this is being attacked -
no that's that's fine yeah that's
ridiculous
okay so I'll play here nope don't play
there No check yourself
okay here
don't get bored came to safety yeah just
some random move that tracks the
position
don't have DNA couple miles do it ya
know so that's it's all different
if you system there's a new computer new
Mouse yeah yeah everything's different
yeah if you every like day it just
improves we'll call it an improvement I
actually do like it the second I touched
it I'm like oh no this mouse isn't gonna
work but now I love it just keeps a
warrior a spawn let's go little pong
could a little pawn the could the little
pawn it could a little pawn that could
get a little crazy over here yeah this
is just a five-minute game no income is
wrecked let me take a look no no this
guy right here - right there
we can't take a rook I'll make a knight
check you can promote you take his rook
he make a knight
let's see what do we got here hasn't me
oh my queen is not hanging I'm gonna see
it come on we got to win you can't at
this rating we can't believe it oh my
gosh oh my gosh what is going what is
going on here sure okay all right all
right all right free move that see you
should be free moving rook takes Queen
check very exciting y'all check
intimidate some
take the other poncho quick take the
other pawn Oh
go pari tours we've seen you before this
is getting intense it's very exciting
stuff to draw a lot that's fine
he's gonna take that and then then
you're gonna trade everything for some
reason it's not looks like he got the
same amount of puns now somehow don't
trade all the puns don't trade all the
puns cuz then you'll win so you'll have
to take that one but then don't trade
the other ones no opposition looks wrong
do all the deep stuff push well [ __ ]
alright take spawn run your king
probably due to do not stalemate them
please do not go over here
didn't you can't steal min them okay
yeah there you go just random of gold
all right Ryan Chester yeah don't forget
you're my can get you my go let me do
this do that that was so close but I
mean come on we were way up on time well
done yeah open all right we're bringing
it bringing it I don't know if we can
get back to 2000 but we got the red guy
we got the right guy for the job here
[Laughter]
now we're playing high rated people
except coconut come on mm-hmm now here's
windmill of doom let's give that guy I
windmill of doom let's go that ago all
right birthday party was very funny mr.
Joe
yeah he's and champagne okay just clear
all right just under the influence
oh wait so I can't do that because they
can see it right it's like they
shouldn't do the Primos
well I mean they can say but they'd have
to be they probably um different screen
so it's probably a lot more likely
they're hearing us than actually seeing
it because they'd have to flip over to
one screen where they're watching you
play and then switch back to the game so
it seems unlikely so I do okay so if you
want to like be sneaky show arrows I
mean that they're spending the time to
go back every move to look at the string
whatever go back this yeah people were
screaming look at the time dude people
were dying dude the drama was building
oh yeah we were like you go to this
window this is a Ben Franklin over him
so 57 on Twitch but they usually are
pretty split what are we on YouTube I've
lost to end this 174 so we're much more
popular on YouTube that's interesting
hi from Germany good to see a majority
attack all right Caleb Denby down here
to tell me what people are saying funny
things about you Barry on the border
so all that really matters though is
tonight and your night's game hopefully
you got all the stuff out your system
you shrug it off
speaking of get on the screen here the
chess worm just come come here so we can
see you do I want to interview you about
your big game today yeah so what
happened in your game today against
Perry yeah I can't see either one of you
right now yeah II know them for some
reason see whatever you just keep
crushing people right that's all the
matters at this point quick get more
people down well they're talking about
something else so you focus on me yeah I
want to do this I mean say I want to do
that yeah starting to question
hey there's more people watching than
people in the studio but we're getting
paid right now you're sitting at home
watching this exactly I can't now I'd
like to do this the highest rated player
in the night's tourney
we got a national master and like a
woman's weight he takes back of the pond
yeah people playing in the Knights yeah
and push to here or you can kick the
bishop out and then you know do a little
stutter step stutter step okay Perry I
can't hear Caleb when you're talking can
I go up again looking right at him thank
you sorry wouldn't know everybody's
parently watching at work getting paid
right now maybe oh yeah yeah mine five
buy paid maybe where everyone's getting
paid for this I do a center step into
this take back with the got it Perry
that's the point
oh then sighs it's awesome to the stream
there's more people on camera than there
is
work to do what's going on here this is
the work hmm if you play queen bee
threat again doesn't never see the
threat it's a great this must be a
violation of the TOS no we've been over
it we've already we've already had this
conversation it's not cheating that's
it's well advertised that we got
multiple people didn't giving you I pre
move let's move like a lowercase they
see the threat what okay
I've seen your idea it's close to being
stellar maybe maybe get your last last
piece in the game it's the best we're
not that some evil intentions yep knows
the pawn break the final straw the one
that broke the camel's back that one
that's it yeah
no wait don't recapture were you gonna
recapture on them dopey fortune don't
report don't ya forked get them good
that's how we work here team Perry you
got a lot to learn from this guy also I
just saw somebody come in is that drew
get in here drew Danny you over there
still who's like a desk get down here
well duh
Zippo let's go drew come say hi this is
debatable this is this is get in here
drew say hi to the stream yeah yeah
friendly warning if he ducked slightly
they'll see if this that's true yeah we
had to bring a roomful of heavy hitters
just to beat willow I'm gonna play 95
now thank you for the game well yeah
okay bye stream All Right see it true
that'll work come on get back to work
so who's technically supposed to be
playing the people it's Wednesday Ryan
Chester plays the people there are so
many pieces birthday playing the people
not today but he has a birthday are you
guys really pumped about the premiere
tonight on YouTube Caleb denby's Road mm
oh yeah tonight sorry yeah one the
handsome yeah really popular guys
they'll go to that class I'm very very
exactly not today but he has a birthday
we're celebrating huh no interesting
I'm too late my chest is too interested
real long talking trash first guy you
played what what you say they got the
weaker player to leave and got four more
coaches
[Music]
[Music]
I love how Danny is pretty on top of
that or did always say that did always
say that good job Danny
but I've been demoted to an friends who
used to be Jonathan Bobby do wanna go
straight hey Bobby some point we should
start just making up names to Steve
Vettius Danny like that okay to this man
so you haven't lost the game yet no I've
not ever on the stream everything is
gone windmill if you'd like to apply at
the club we have a job opening money as
soon as a guy it's very common yeah
people are debating about what countries
are from a lot of their names D for
either a forty-foot with the pawn or
with the bishop sort of guidelines now
keep going keep going you want to rip it
open while his pieces are misplaced
I think people are wanting to challenge
you and play for the vacancy that will
be caused when we had to fire peri
perfect with this covered attacked
doesn't they're quite a ring to it it's
not the same but yeah take the bun okay
the only office yes the only button you
know when loads of material you know
[Music]
this movies check and buy this move I
mean take that's checking how's it check
that is a bishop way far away discovered
oh you know this car still can yeah I
mean zippo cat
I don't make a sad face hold on I'm
texting
we're totally crushing this person one
time we're check and for example if they
play in a bedroom like we'd have to you
can take with your Bishop check Bishop
III did you tell us what Ryan's online
rating is for what your online rating I
guess they don't care about your USCF
it's is it cocktail bowlers are too high
it's
yes yes we're gonna use a button was
here if you can also just keep playing
games on this account you take care of
that let's get that really good to
people want to play me I played on
Tuesdays 1513 13,000 so 1400 rabbit all
right oh yeah your drops to get us back
to 2000 that's it okay I don't know yes
you can see the stream schedule there on
your screen
I'm on Tuesdays Ryan is on Wednesdays
Thursdays is GM Fridays Mike comer yeah
Thursday night right APM is gonna be to
hear about that brand new ladies night
stream maybe push your song definitely
check it out and then here is that what
it is ladies play the people to do 1970
do what they say it was we said 1300
here and start doing that
[Music]
Niq because people are looking up you're
eating is it 1300 Blitz 1400 rapid how
did you ask the question and then how
did you know what his name is
there's no way they know what my name is
it's a fish song
just got this email from Ryan Chester
okay
all many Queens does one guy at least
more we can take
yeah this bishop hanging it's very
important aunt I still made tricks I
think you zip okay next victim
alright are you getting coffee because I
need some more yeah alright
Caleb I will definitely need some help
on this one what's this what's this
let's see 1619 pair you got an excellent
position against the London we won't
talk about the result did he win yeah I
got talk about it I can't remember all
right thank you sir
I like it who is that college-age guy in
the st. Louis jacket behind you guys
which one are you don't know hurting me
well it's college aged college age you
still have the Charlotte Ronson Brian
Chester yeah yeah we're celebrating your
19th like sure for the road mm
Wednesdays at 6:30 here Firestone you
told YouTube it's at 6:30 right now
today all right thank you sir if you
want to be a cool guy just like me
road to 2000 that's the class for you
yeah we should have you on more often I
agree with that
okay then be on this too I don't hear I
don't want them to hear my Danny meet me
for a second because right probably what
does it matter it's okay
you
so if you do that on twitch though a lot
of it like it's you can't watch it
another movement built on YouTube
Hey look at the llamas you know neo tres
I found the magic black box yeah there's
like a magic black box why well and you
need a line for your bishop so it was
nice to know you did everyone
are we all muted Danny are we all
you guys come on
anything of importance no mucus
okay you guys can hear us out there
where we muted because that's Danny I
don't like this mouse either what is
this just can't wait to have a normal
Mouse so I said this is not a normal
Mouse it looks like it looks like a
spaceship like you really can't see the
yeah actually pretty good now I can
cancel well yeah you probably want to
develop your bishop here there's one key
square in this position
do you notice we for you can't lose
control of this square or else you'd be
for Danny what's Bram talking about I
switch the screens so I don't see the
messages or Lawrence yes see because if
you can push that pawn forward to square
to d5 it's gonna be bad for you so you
want that square under lock well that
yeah how's that lock be fine I know but
it's funnier for me to say this I know
that you're on is a big importance ah we
lost L son I just unsubscribed this is
just awful guys sorry to hear it oh
right yeah what more do you want
I'm unsubscribing to go watch this and
watch something else alright you can
threaten checkmate I like doing that
look at that big square it's an outpost
for your pieces d5 yeah whatever you
want there and it'll be good the Queen
there the night there put a bishop there
why not
my gut tells me to take it you can you
might have to but you can't okay
yeah challenge us on my chests st. Louis
chess club now you're not gonna get
checkmated that's a bonus okay now
you're up
New York's can probably be better placed
that's a square
so what's the most annoying piece that
he has right good night yeah so how do
you get rid of it I gotta move my night
sure and then kick it away yeah that'll
work
I suppose you've ignored what he did
with a four and maybe maybe that move
deserved a response yeah so yeah we're
actually thinking about getting some of
the lectures live so that's something to
look forward to especially twitch in
YouTube so it should be twitch on
YouTube it's I mean Danny our band would
know a lot more about it they just was
just disgusting do you guys know about
the Karen's Cup coming up online
audience yeah a lot of people have been
asking about it and yeah you can go to
us just champs get all the info just
just champs calm okay okay you have to
defend the bishop in a very specific way
that is not v8 okay mr. Rick B it would
be bad news for you because that I
forget
fort you'd get attacked live lectures I
think would be really awesome IDs have
something we we want to try we don't
want to do it all the time with the
testimony Europe has to move and then he
takes your vision the quality of the
stream would go down a little bit but
it's also there's a lot of pros you guys
would be able to ask stuff live yeah so
it's a interesting thing we want to try
out quality will not go down oh
absolutely no reason that's a live
stream oh yeah yeah no challenges it
doesn't matter what you're eating is 900
yeah trust me
what okay okay so I want to kick this
night out so correct or don't want to
defend beat you know you want to defend
it again pre-move know there's an
increment here so you don't want to play
Bishop takes for sure right
what was the increment 393 can we take
that night before you take the broken
English all right good match good match
all right oh that was scary these I can
order oh it's one of the top okay oh
good sorry oh yeah 99 if five sir
yeah it'd be cool if we do the lectures
live it'll kind of like be like you're
there it depends on how the lecturer is
maybe no to do that I get this happens
to me a lot
mm does this do I want to do that I feel
like I don't want to do that you can
play h6 if you don't I'm also worried
about the night coming down here so well
that's fine you do have a good move
Jonathan mentions I didn't hear it so
what I'd like to do is go right here you
could do that and try to take his bishop
yeah but also pin him yourself yeah
thank you for our Bishop g4 but
something on g4 and good things weapon
oh no I'm gonna do that all right then
usually in such positions they play like
Ricky to defend their stuff
but will they just gonna keep my night
away right in a minute so what was the
point of doing that just to see if they
do it perfect all right
what good people do I'm gonna check
Twitter sometimes I play that and it was
a kick a night you take on f2 sounds
right okay well I mean farther than b6
is where you want to put it also when
you play a six and Bishop a7 they never
see that thing is on the line with their
king so later l'attaque Tagore
you won't see it either cuz your bishops
gonna be really far away but it's like
gonna be there
what does who think you put this Bishop
on a7 like so far away and then neither
one of you are gonna see it for the rest
of the game but there's gonna be like
tactics eventually ships on this little
thing on that whole diagonal there's
always tactics all the time and then
nobody ever sees because it's far away
yeah if you're like b6 then like they'll
see it like a seven that's really far
away
so that's too far for most human minds
and and I'm not discounting myself do
you do it and you wait for them to push
you away no it's fine to go away first
cuz look he played it anyways so if you
didn't go away beforehand you have to
right right all right move that piece
over there nice yeah that feels like
cheating Jacob was such good place
yeah move that piece over there
the last thing white would want to do is
take on e5 come on do it
the last thing white wouldn't want to do
all right so there's a couple things
going on you know you'd like to be able
to move your C pawn right but your
Knights and I was like yeah can I just
go here it's math you can but maybe
every once a week for that okay oh hello
Beth say hi to the stream well so what
we do is Caleb feeds me the movies right
so so I would want to eventually do this
so this needs to go somewhere else it's
here or here or here and then he goes
there and then I go there I figured it
all on my own
[Laughter]
we don't want to waste your time are you
going home or were you done all right
okay see you better so JJ chess he's got
a little thing next to him this is all
verified verified
he's the actual JJ chef it wasn't me
that means
maybe you had to take that night that's
okay no more because your iPod is weak
and there's night attacks or deep on all
right you want to play us you don't know
if it was sent or not you may want to
kick his night away we got twenty
challenges in d5 or there's make oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
friendly chest you should be able to see
if you precious or not if you have a
game waiting and the thing will be
spinning around saying you're waiting
for us to accept enough time and
increment do we challenge you that
that's up to Ryan what do you want to
play Ryan quick games quick games my
quick games means slow games fives good
three two is good oh that's good move
yeah do that I'm out alright Bishop
takes pawn yeah yeah yeah
Oh put the plate okay alright thank that
pawn that goes nothing now take his free
pawn that was fine you can do that first
it's got a pawn it's undefended and it
is attacked one time okay all right
he's got a pawn look carefully under
this one that's one of them there's
another one I'm assuming he's gonna
defend that one over there no but at the
risk of losing the other one on the
other square can you point to it
please don't tell us the notation
because that doesn't know Jacqueline
with check
Jack
gangs over there look there first
you know my women I'm gonna take it very
nice right
rook takes rook takes you can just
right-click and then or just click
anywhere yeah three minutes is good to
look through mouths you're on that leaf
on that was undefended in the attacked
one time we knew we'd take it eventually
oh look see that Bishop they come yeah
yeah he's got a kid nope I gonna make a
queen what happened Bonet removing it
yeah it's that good
you just push
let's go get on the Queen means our with
more than bishops
don't get boards trained to play 102
play against Mike comer know very
exciting everyone's waiting for Friday
still man prep the other color variation
lacing move that isn't rookie for it
looking for is the only move you're not
allowed to play I thought you would be
sarcastic that's all you think I hear
the moves
undefeated undefeated all right Jimmy no
sorry we got the Grandmaster coming in
tomorrow so we'll get that back in 2000
okay where we at what are we at was a
pipe dream last night
go Jimmy but undefeated yeah you're
gonna play the minutes I'm not oh well
what time we know I think it's
theoretically this could be the last
game if you want it to be but that's are
you gonna keep going keep the stream we
keep going if you want I mean do you
what do you know I just got a text from
I'm picking up blaze from ESP so it's
you always you go say SP he likes to
stay there well so I'm gonna stay a
little bit longer
no well the kid oh I'm getting up a
second okay so yeah what do you what do
you can you get us back to 2000 I can't
do you have what it takes yeah need
something is there some tough challenge
challengers those very same thing or
happen last time and then it takes for
so many London's yeah I know
hmm we can't control it not too much I
want to play so bad
we got Caleb on deck so please bring
your A game see or be hydrated and bring
like your C or D game that also helps if
you promise to watch that'll get you
bearing six o'clock at the club
premiering at 6:30 on YouTube so I don't
know why we wouldn't just run this until
the premiere and then we can just sign
up for it you know I would have to be
here forever
I'd have to judge the class at some
point so you're moving into six o'clock
now yes so it's gonna be start so people
tonight only those watching the stream
will know that there's a class tonight
it's true it's six o'clock no it's at
the Chess Club so if you are under two
thousand and years wondering I don't I
get to two thousand what street should I
take they able to then literally bring
us on a road that's the thing is a 2000
I don't even have to know what street
you're on because I'm gonna drive right
and I mean but then he dumps you off on
your own next time could you maybe like
1500 we'll start there you know you can
get out see if you like the place get
back on the bus I'll take you all the
way to 2000 from that wasn't interesting
what's up scroll up slightly on the
screen
I bet goes is weird what's what's
changed
maybe we zoomed out presumed dead oh
yeah now you can't see like our our name
and you can't see that the top 50 yeah
hey tech guy I was waiting till Danny
came you know real bird
I dunno elevator all right okay I'm
gonna do this that's a great move
especially if he takes it also if he
doesn't okay the clocks near at the
bottom how did you do that we hire Danny
Machuca
to be our tech guy just take it also
we're using oh yes don't do it now you
might want to take that fun a few things
you think like a trapped might get
trapped I don't like taking the pond
yeah yeah 24 this is free they're saying
scroll up yeah we tried to pull you up
how does it look now it's fine so you
just can't see our name on the thing
right yeah you know alright sorry no you
should write a thunderbolt yeah I see it
now some day if the road takes me
you want to castle here you'll get
checkmated for sure oh yeah
just believe in yourself we'll treat a
few pieces before you castle all right I
do want my other open that see okay fine
as is we're getting there we still can't
see with our name and our rating
we're getting there we're getting there
oh we got the guy see we got the guy on
what do you need well yeah what I think
whenever we're under 2,000 we're just
gonna block out our will publish our
reading again okay all right you want to
get your pieces in the game now you can
invade don't
solty close I'd love to play you but I
play on Tuesday over let Caleb you have
to play yesterday attack it's one way to
go about it if your name is salty clown
and you're playing on a day when I play
then we're going to night to there like
it's another piece towards using phone
cheater nice cheater how good I love
calling people cheating what no this
really seems like mattad she didn't get
XD ya know like there's nothing criminal
on there isn't
the old guy is too loud and the young
guy is too low well this guy is Mike
it's and that guy is in the corner but
I'll just shout ya know you had another
birthday so I why you want Perry back in
the room cuz it's by comparison sign up
undefeated bring in that rook bring in
that rug it's time pre-move check with
the rook you could just take his pawn
with the rook yep checking him on the
second screen
why are you doing with the broken up I
don't know what Jonathan's talk about
with Queen a3 highly illegal Oh
what's your queen that's why I only play
one day a week and definitely never this
late that's why that is why I my things
at noon today he'll have a so calm and
patient that I started to think he is
related to Yasser that was held good but
will allow it just Lama Lord behind you
yeah we're in the good hands at the
lemon Lord so you can take an a2 with
the queen cheat and play Queen x-ray so
bless you I can't let you find the check
do it on the next turn you're probably
gonna have a checkmate I don't know
where it's gonna be hopefully a third
don't know how it's gonna work I said
that a minute figured out you know yeah
Jon you don't know what you're in for
we got Caleb here now to crush you with
this why is this the camera yeah
okay so yes wait like he blacked it out
here so when people hack us something
god only knows what Danny did yeah oh
the tech guy so I think they're really
worried because I can hack you and look
at your face now do it to what end
I don't find other to you not working at
work I don't you don't so I have facial
recognition on this phone and it won't
recognize my face without my glasses
it's probably a good thing
yeah what if you change all right sorry
it's the checkmate how many are there I
see one mean I count three main ones
where was the other ones the rut can go
there then the only one that I saw
immediately yeah that was my first mate
I saw eyes last one and then kale
explain you're undefeated sir that's
right there's that game cuz because this
guy this guy drew that guy
Sophie ray yeah yeah he taught me to
play rookie for all right here we go all
right Sophie yeah majority attack 277
bits one bit for every twitch viewer and
person in the studio sorry Sophie yeah
so V is less game of me your 5 seconds
so we don't think she died for every
employee for the game right now why John
yeah Thank You Jordan yeah
what is your ego rating mr. Ryan Chester
what's your rating yes yes yeah also you
only play in like staff tournament yeah
so Fran that's what I figured oh no I
don't know what to do here yeah you can
take it alright Siri Siri what is Ryan's
USCF rating Syria what's my USCF rating
Bishop b4 is a good move I think Bishop
to b4 seems like a move he did do that I
get that allowing you to where there's
random letters a little testing us I
know they're sitting on the keyboard
there's no safe King up at night you
could break in the center well yeah
we'll play you John we're sending
perfect so you want to prepare it though
okay then what happens when he pushes
so you can't push it was a hard three oh
now I can do it when your pieces get
attacked
do you have a deep sense of dread that
kind of fills you and consumes you more
panic than dread panic yeah but like you
know long-term panic its deep-rooted
okay right so you don't like it
sometimes it bubbles to the surface
sometimes I just feel it inside you know
to challenge oh ya we have to play
majority attack he's our only yeah but
donator so yeah we gotta get you in here
just challenge challenges so yeah Danny
key put the link in one more time it's
us we're a st. Louis Chess Club
missed a chance it's just rude to take
more pieces at that point what was wrong
yeah you could have taken the bishop
instead of the rep well I mean nobody
kicks what time controls well I'm gonna
be coming up so 3 plus though is great
yeah yeah is there anyone at the club
whoever started as a student and then
became an instructor there well we
operate like a student it's not really
like a classroom well yeah I mean people
have started working here not knowing
how to play and then they end up being
pretty decent chess players like I don't
think Perry was playing chess at all and
now he's so there's no so it's just cuz
you're here it's just club you learned
how to play over time I came here in
fifth grade Wow he's a seventh grader
now so I mean those a while ago
14 years old you could have taken that
pawn special rule French for this dream
fairly good nice gentle the file user
pieces yeah so John core disco was
really hoping to play alright John cuz
he's a big fan when I was he's always
watching her stuff eat real quick fine
wine Stoppers so when you start fish to
be to nine-hundred watching this do we
have
yeah challenge rated of course yeah
definitely rated on all the place
alright yeah thank you
don't forget your everybody take a break
off all right Thank You Ryan Chester
undefeated he left it all on the board
all right all right
see Ryan changed to three plus zero yeah
we got get John we gotta do majority
attack first though cuz he gave us money
in you know but then we'll get we'll get
John okay you got a less than 15 how
does that affect our stream for majority
attack and play them all right you can
leave it on are you gonna be right here
than what to call you and joy yeah okay
majority attack yeah we want only rated
we got to get back to 2008 at three plus
so now this guy's a question mark guy
and do we have it yeah by so you know
I'm scared
just let me know I'm afraid all right
we'll start with developing our pieces
I'm not afraid only because I'm not
playing if I was playing I'm terrified
yeah yeah no this is good the roles are
reversed from yesterday I got another
London I ought to say I really enjoyed
this side of the table yeah you know I'd
never lose I like this side of the table
a lot too I think both sides of the
table yeah just get cash sold alright
I'll show you guys my big idea in the
London oh okay develop your stuff
develop my stuff
but specifically don't develop this guy
or this guy because they get confused
and then you can trade off their Bishop
interesting this bishops usually really
good they usually put it here cuz it's
better there but this bishops bad that
bishops good so I like to trade them
it's my big idea
it's your favorite twitch streamer
what's up znation
mmm okay so we sloth bro could take this
night but I could also not take this
night now I'm in directly controlling
this square with my queen put a knight
there you're doing great
looking great such a big-time teacher
how the London works
if only I had a class Wednesdays at 6
o'clock about getting to mm huh let's be
honest that's basically my life cool
I'll have to check out the class we're
starting off more basic though we're
starting off earlier ideas that can help
everybody take me on the road tonight
okay
take you if you're a thousand takings
1,200 easy okay yeah easy if you're you
know 1,800 like you 1900s yeah then how
far am I gonna go tonight no you'll get
like 15 20 points Wow 15 points I'll
take it it's math I've worked out the
equation that's just how it works we're
gonna take our queenside space and we're
gonna run with it
how often do I play over the board
really not that much anymore I played in
a staff tournament I'll probably play on
like one or two tournaments throughout
the year mmm you know which is why my
rating doesn't go up because I just play
and I play against like 17 1800s and
then I lose sometimes and then my
reading goes down and I never play any
what he looks like appropriate so please
keep sharing your thought process move
it yeah people like it we actually teach
them stuff yeah sometimes they say they
like it but then they get bored and
leave don't eat too much yeah okay he's
gonna play this one but I'm not gonna be
afraid because I'm gonna put my rook on
the file wasn't Caleb went all the staff
tournaments cuz he's the best yeah hey
that guy sounds pretty smart you guys a
nation you know that guy he says you're
his favorite streamer well you know we
can't all have good taste
okay so he's threatening to take care
it's my guys not the funded enough times
so I'm gonna go here defending my guy
enough times okay he wants he wants his
own space I could go to the square of
this square hmm
hope I don't get checkmated here that'd
be very embarrassing all right if you
got this for say I'm taking a quick
break everything okay all right goodbye
Jonathan never won forever he's never
coming back this is the last you'll see
of Jonathan's rants yep all right so
I've played badly this game somehow I
think maybe it's still fine I think I
have this move which looks terrible and
is terrible but maybe it's not all right
instead of worrying about what he's
gonna do over here I'm gonna ignore him
and try to get activity on the queenside
problems will arise later but I'm hoping
the problems I caused over here will be
too much for him will just be too much
he'll just get so worried about his
Queens side that he forgets to check me
at me so I can take this it opens the
file and it allows these six breaks but
it prevents him from playing f6 which
looks like a problem I could also play
g6 hoping to get keep things a bit more
closed but I think I like taking here
rings is rook into the game as well but
now I'm opening a lot of files a lot of
files over here thinking about rook a to
rather than taking on c3 also thinking
about playing g6 is it might stymie some
of his activity
I don't like this g6 movie I've decided
now I'm considering f6 I'm also
considering moving faster it's a big
consideration I'm having I like this f6
move I don't know if it actually works
tactically from what I could tell it did
because of pens on the Queen
man can you imagine if I lost my first
game down the stream okay Big Time Queen
tix because of tactics
13 seconds left it's gonna be tight it's
gonna be tight
where's shruts took off ID you have to
take off soon another gamer to here all
right we're gonna get on this open file
he's on the worse open file excite all
the squares covered we're gonna take
here then we're gonna get in we got in
all right okay yeah probably like in the
next 15 minutes or so I gotta go so this
is just a fancy pawn trade I know are
you gonna keep going or you wanna have
this room we could end the stream
because Danny sounds like he's got stuff
to do okay let's play let's play John
and then call it a day I made a queen
array oh he didn't even want you okay
good game majority attack thank you so
much for the bits you uh you nearly had
me I played I played without my word my
greatest we're gonna go wrong I think
the c-4 move probably was a bit
premature in putting this knight on e4 I
didn't make as much sense as I thought
it did so just kind of walked into this
f3 business yeah maybe you know I should
just play b5 or c4 right it's my cover I
don't either
big screen time for sneaking around get
a beverage all right oh man is Jonathan
gay all right well your lessons canceled
stream the stream never dies they see me
they see me one time get a losing
position and they think you know
everybody's got to play the London oh
yeah all right let's see the same idea
and prove that it's not as bad as I made
it look
I also like that not getting to 2,000
because we're on the road yeah which
means you never actually really good
right right
most people are on that road their whole
life hey I'm gonna take you to 1999
we're all on that road yeah it's like
you're on the road to being a GM right
like you're not there I'm making an
Italian we just on the road nobody knows
what direction I'm going I was like my
favorite book the road where they walk
on a road for the whole book that's a
pretty good book have you read that book
I haven't because it's it sounds higher
variable though Isaac when we were
growing up he heard about the book and
he had very very low opinions of it I
really fantastic was great yeah yeah
it's a father and son are saying that
because he didn't I have to say I did
enjoy it a lot because I knew he would
hate it but I actually did enjoy it okay
it's a good Father's Day this guy knows
things about the London fun story this
this queen bee five and a four ideas
something strong players do against me
hey Chesky so the stream goes on I don't
miss a stream going on no one knows I
don't know does is less than actually
get canceled town was that a joke okay
was I could play beef or I could play c4
yeah Perris around the corner somewhere
he probably here to play c4
so I'm just planning on the side where I
have more space and whites not as good
as me so he's not playing in this
library has more space the key to chess
play where you can look his pieces are
all awkward cuz he has a beat pawn in
the way it's bishops way up here aye
bishop supporting the side where I have
more space and look at how much space I
have now doesn't stand a chance now I'm
just gonna double my rooks I was
wondering how far up you go yeah I could
go to a two but I'm not feeling that
ambitious just yet I'm gonna just say
might say hi to parry and is that what
this is called is this called berry pies
and people yeah yeah yeah berry we're
Brian oh we gotta kill him yeah well
idea what's that broke on the file
okay now I'm gonna reverse the order of
my pieces because you do want the rook
in front hi Caleb it's closed why don't
we see anymore Jonathan Shaun's lectures
close to the spelling of the flying
sheep ate my homework what a name okay
it's finally coming after me on this
Queen side here Kings side rather note
it Matt's gonna play this f6 move again
I worked so well for me last time kind
of did I don't know if it should have
but it did I'm gonna take here that was
pawn breaks or not as easy I have a I
have a target er two making many many
weaknesses many many many weaknesses
yeah
a KB gun what to do now
follow the logical plan of course this
is waiting for the opportunity to play
Bishop III we're all just waiting on
this move aren't we that's can't I play
g6e the idea of playing f5 all right h4
was maybe too much you too maybe it's
all getting too much let's defend this
pawn first threaten that guy did you
have to play Bishop a3 next turn
yeah right now right now oh no my my
pond Oh dad okay you didn't see it
everybody say you saw though you
calculated everything yep it wasn't a
perpetual on your end yep yeah cuz my
bishop covers this yeah it was perfect
yeah it looks magic I'll work out
take that guy okay good move play this
one I like giving check resume David
bush
why not give check first check is fun as
described previously I wish I'm gonna
wrap it up in place John this is our
last game yeah I think oh sweet thanks
guys everybody that got to play today we
had a lot of fun here so do come back to
check out his premiere which is gonna
come up in how many hours from now one
and a half hours and half-hours check
out the premiere youtube.com youtube and
other than that if you want to see us
again on Twitch come back tomorrow we
got the Grand Master at 3:00 p.m.
Central Time so we got tight on this
goal of again coming in here crushing
you guys getting us back to 2000
absolutely so we'll see you guys
tomorrow